a new energy a new audience new stories
keep watching to find out the candid
Thoughts The Witcher showrunner and
executive producer had about the show's
big name exit fans of the expansive
fantasy franchise The Witcher are still
reeling over the news that Henry Cavill
is departing the role of protagonist
geralt of Rivia in the Netflix series
based upon it after cattle's final
outing in the parts of geralt in the
show's upcoming third season the
character will be played by Liam
Hemsworth in season four a casting
choice that has fans divided to say the
least an online change.org petition to
restore cattle to the role has almost
275 000 signatures as of this video and
many viewers of the show are
understandably skeptical of recasting a
Show's main character myth story but no
online petition is more powerful than
the Man of Steel and cattle is most
likely exiting The Witcher due to his
newly reinvigorated commitment to
playing Superman in the DC Universe some
fans believe it's because of his
displeasure with the direction of The
Witcher thus fans won't be seeing him
again in the role of geralt anytime soon
you can reasonably assume that The
Witcher showrunner Lauren Schmidt
hisrick also wishes geralt didn't have
to be recast still on a recent interview
with deciders she spoke optimistically
and enthusiastically about the change
and what it means for the future of the
series this Rick isn't worried about A
disruption of the show's creative
momentum instead she says she sees it as
a positive she said you know I will say
that change is also energy change also
brings a different energy so to us
that's just part of continuing to roll
forward into this franchise more
open-minded fans of The Witcher might
understand what she means and will look
forward to seeing exactly what kind of
new energy this admittedly huge change
will bring to the show and even most of
the more close-minded ones will probably
still check it out recasting geralt of
Rivia wasn't the only subject addressed
during Lauren Schmidt history's decider
interview but not just the upcoming
third and fourth seasons of The Witcher
and The Witcher blood origin on the way
but also various animated projects like
The Witcher nightmare of the wolf and
even a family-friendly animated series
coming in the near future The Witcher
franchise is growing incredibly fast and
historic also spoke and how she sees the
series fitting into the fantasy genre
that so many fans love she said one of
the things that we believe strongly is
that fantasy is actually for everyone
there have been points in time in
history that it's a very narrow audience
I think all of those different access
points if you will all that does is make
people fall in love with the genre more
which is what we want she's also not
worried about the franchise hitting any
kind of critical mass regarding audience
endurance saying it's interesting
because could there be fatigue I
actually don't think so I think the
stories are so vast and also so varied
and I think there's so many different
ways into the world that we could keep
doing this forever and we'd never run
out of stories
for years fans will get their chance to
see the next phase of Netflix's The
Witcher Sago and the four episode blood
origin prequel mini-series hits a
streaming platform on December 25th 2022
and season three of the witcher's main
series which will star Henry Cavill is
set to come out sometime next year
this is where we point where he's bored
for good look I promise to change the
Public's tune about you at least allow
me to try
[Music]